[Evans] Let's try to define a hash function that has these properties.
What we want the hash function to do is to take a string as its input--
we'll call the hash function hashstring--
and it will produce as its output a number between 0 and b.
We also need another input to our hash string
which is going to be the size of the hash table.
So that will be the second input is the size of the hash table, the number of buckets.
What we haven't seen yet that we're going to need for this function
is a way to turn a string into a number.
Python provides an operation to do that. It's called ord for ordinal.
And what ord takes as its input is a 1-letter string
and produces as its output a number.
The actual mapping between strings and numbers is not so important.
We just want something that's going to map different strings to different numbers.
There's another operator that goes in the opposite direction
that takes in a number and outputs the 1-letter string that corresponds to that number.
The property these functions have is they're inverses,
that if we take the character corresponding to the ordinal
corresponding to any 1-letter string--we'll call that alpha--
what we get as a result is the same alpha that we passed in.
Let's try a few examples in the Python interpreter to see how ord and chr work.
We'll print ord('a'), and when we run that we see we get the number 97.
If we try print ord('A'), that's different. We get 65.
And if we print ord('B'), we get 66.
So the numbers are sort of sensible.
B is higher than A. The lower case letters have different ordinals than the upper case.
If we try lower case b, we should expect to get 98, and that is indeed what we get.
These are the numbers based on the ASCII character encoding.
What the actual numbers are are not very important for us
other than that we get different numbers for different letters.
So we'll be able to use the results of ord to make different strings hash to different values
and just to show that they are inverses.
If we do ord('u') and then chr of that,
what we get back is the single letter string u that we started with.
The limit of ord is it only works on 1-letter strings.
If it provided a mapping from any string to a number that would be useful for a hash table,
then we'd be done, but it doesn't do that.
If we try running it on a multi-letter string, we get an error.
It says that ord expects a single character but it got a string of length 7.
So we're going to need to use ord only on single letter strings.
So with ord we have a way of converting strings to numbers,
converting single character strings to numbers.
The other property we need our hash function to have
is that the output number is always between 0 and b -1.
We need it to be in that range because we're going to use that to index the list
to find the bucket where that string belongs.